here's what I'm thinking I'm going okay
the more money you have
the more margin that you should have if
you're handling it correctly and a lot
of folks that I know that have high
incomes like this they're not spending
all of the money like it's not part of
their
they have a lot of extra that they're
like okay I can give this and I can
invest this and but it's not like oh
great now I can go see more movies and
now I can buy more steaks and now I can
do you see does that make sense like at
the end of the day you're gonna come to
a point where it's like this is my
lifestyle and I've just got to be able
to manage my my lifestyle anything on
top of that is gravy and it's cool but
it sounds like these people just want if
if you can just learn to manage your
lifestyle without a bunch of creep
without a bunch of inflated habits you
would be happy probably with the 75 000
oh which is we've seen the stats of hey
people who make six figures they're
living a paycheck to paycheck too